what you're about to hear is police
officers discussing a woman who's just
been strip searched
[Music]
back in 2013 koshkadoff says she tried
to help a teenage boy during a stop and
search by police but when her
intervention landed her in a Cell she
says female officers assaulted her
they were you know grabbing at my
breasts they stuck their hands between
my legs they said um you know they'd rip
the piercing out of my
um ear and then they said oh let's see
if she's got any more and they stuck
their hand between my legs last year
koshka received compensation and an
apology from the Metropolitan Police for
the sexist and derogatory language of
the officers but a damning new report
has found that misogyny and predatory
behavior are prevalent across forces the
review team also looked at hundreds of
files on the vetting of officers there
were a significant number where we
thought that somebody just shouldn't
have been employed or if they were going
to be employed there should have been a
pattern of supervision of them greater
than normal that that just wasn't
happening I think we're safe to say that
over the last couple of years the police
have employed hundreds of people that we
think they shouldn't have done the
potential scale of the problem raises
serious concerns about Public Safety
after Sarah everard's murder
her killer Wayne cousins a serving
member of the Metropolitan Police had
been part of a WhatsApp group with other
officers who sent messages described as
repulsive and misogynistic it has to be
not just a type but a wave of change it
has to be people feeling they can come
forward report things and and then when
that when that is proved and that
person's proved to have done that that
wrongdoing they need to be gone as
quickly as possible and that process is
too slow the Met says they welcome the
report and will consider opportunities
for learning and Improvement adding
being ruthless in reading the Met of
those who corrupt our integrity is
Central to commissioner Mark rowley's
vision of Reform we are setting clear
expectations of behavior and are
developing data and Technology to
identify those who are not fit to serve
we will succeed with the vast majority
of our honest and dedicated officers and
staff
change is needed now as the review's
leader put it officers shouldn't just
represent Society they need to represent
the best of it it seems like we're a
long way off that Becky Cottrell Sky
News